on en parle ce matin avec julian colling
depuis moscou bonjour julian pour
vladimir poutine ce sommet avec travail
donne est déjà un progrès une victoire
diplomatique
oui en tout cas dans la presse russe
hier et aujourd'hui on se félicite en
tout cas on signale que ce nouveau
rendez vous donc par visioconférence est
plutôt un bon signe ça permet à moindre
frais de garder le contact ouvert un
dialogue serré de perdre et le contact
ouvert un dialogue qui avaient été
ouverts bien sûr au mois de juin avec
donc cette rencontre à genève on sait
pas beaucoup d'illusions par contre à
moscou aujourd'hui sur les avancées
concrètes qu'on peut attendre de ce
rendez vous par exemple le porte parole
de vladimir poutine dimitri peskov
ailleurs déclaré qu' il ne fallait pas
s'attendre à des percées aujourd'hui
c'était simplement encore une fois pour
garder le contact et le dialogue ouvert
mais c'était difficile également selon
lui est bien de reconstruire une
relation vraiment endommagés et ces
derniers mois entre donc l'occident on
peut dire les états unis surtout et la
russie est donc bien sûr le sujet
principal aujourd'hui sera sans doute
l'ukraine car c'est au tour de l'ukraine
justement ce dossier très important que
la tension est encore montée ces
derniers jours vous disiez avec les
troupes notamment russes qui s'approche
donc de la frontière ukrainienne en
russie depuis deux ans parce que des
occidentaux ils redoutent une
intervention russe un peu comme en
géorgie ou en crimée par le passé que
veut vraiment là réussi avec ses
manoeuvres
alors c'est toujours difficile de bien
sûr de savoir exactement ce que pense la
dîme et routine et le kremlin sur ce
dossier en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que on a l'impression que la liberté ne
semble plus vraiment bluffé par rapport
à l'ukraine il a notamment pris la
parole ces derniers jours chose assez
rare pour demander des choses concrètes
et fixer des demandes et les lignes
rouges concrète ce qui n'était pas
forcément le cas auparavant et bien sûr
la demande la plus précise c'est
évidemment que l'ukraine ne fasse jamais
partie de l'otan pour la russie c'est
évidemment la ligne rouge absolue est
également on peut comprendre que voit le
voisin ukrainien et un dossier
extrêmement important pour la russie est
beaucoup plus que pour les états unis
c'est un peu le discours qui est tenu
ici à moscou en disant que voilà les
américains ne devraient pas se soucie
autant de l'ukraine est ne pas vouloir à
ce point aider l'ukraine face à la
russie et un peu se désintéresser de ce
dossier et on peut aussi préciser que
dans la presse russe et les experts
géopolitique russes les plus éminents
sont tous d'accord pour dire que la
russie ne souhaite pas réellement
envahir
l'ukraine de l'est fin le donbass en
tout cas et que c'est beaucoup aussi des
cris d'orfraie qui sont poussés dans les
capitales européennes occidentales et
dans les journaux dans les médias
occidentaux c'est à la remise m cet
alarmisme un petit peu qu'on peut voir à
l'ouest est un petit peu calmé par les
russes et eux ils se contentent de dire
encore une fois que leur but est
seulement préventif c'est de montrer que
désormais ils sont prêts à aller
jusqu'au bout peut-être d'aller encore
plus loin pour défendre leurs intérêts
avec le cren donc mais c'est un message
bien sûr adressé aux états unis en
premier lieu jeudi en coller une depuis
moscou pour france24 merci beaucoup
julian et pardon pour ce léger décalage
parfois entre le le son l'image qui peut
arriver avec un duplex à l'autre bout du
monde